hola buenas noches así es los dos
candidatos a la presidencia de los eeuu
hicieron visitas relámpago a diversos
estados en el caso de donald trump
estuvo en carolina del norte en
wisconsin en pensilvania tratando en un
último intento de disminuir esa ventaja
que le lleva a las encuestas bailén de
aproximadamente 10 puntos en el caso de
joe biden hizo una visita inesperada a
ohio un estado en donde los demócratas
no ganan desde el 60 desde kennedy y los
dos coincidieron en pensilvania es un
estado en donde trump ganó por una
mínima diferencia cuatro años atrás
frente a hillary clinton pero en donde
ahora estaba ir en liderando las
encuestas este es un estado que es un
estado industrial en donde el desempleo
ha golpeado fuertemente y esto pues
básicamente es la manera como cerrarán
los dos candidatos ya a menos de 24
horas de las elecciones y después de una
votación como lo mencionaba récord de
manera anticipada tienes en washington
contanos cómo se está preparando la
capital del país para él
mañana tenemos entendido que varios
comercios edificios están reforzando su
seguridad y que muchos no van a abrir en
este día de elecciones
así es básicamente washington y si se
encuentra blindada muchos edificios en
el centro en el área del congreso en el
área de la casa blanca han colocado
barreras de madera para proteger también
las ventanas en las puertas los bancos
también ante la posibilidad de saqueos y
de protestas el día de mañana igualmente
la seguridad ha sido aumentada en más
personal del servicio secreto de la
policía metropolitana y la alcaldesa
incluso de washington decía pedido a los
residentes que traten de comprar
alimentos para abastecerse para dos o
tres días esto porque el presidente de
donald trump estará aquí en la casa
blanca ha realizado la invitación a 400
personas que estarán viendo los
resultados y por supuesto las
autoridades están alertas